hey guys how's it going it's Justine
today we're going to be unboxing the
GoPro Hero 5 and the hero 5 session so
I'm not even going to say anymore I'm
just going to get right into this
because this has been sitting on my
doorstep all day just waiting for me to
come home
look at this session 5 extra battery I
think this is a mistake buying this but
it's a little micro SD card reader but
we've made quite a mess here let's start
with the hero 5 because that is what I'm
here for what I'm most excited about one
of the best parts about the new GoPro
Hero 5 especially is that it is now
waterproof you don't need an external
housing on it it is already waterproof
it has voice control stabilization touch
display 12 megapixel camera and it
shoots in 4k and it's waterproof up to
33 feet 10 meters ok open you up you've
got this nice little tab here that is
completely neglecting just really great
packaging
one of my favorite accessories for the
previous GoPros was the blackout housing
so I basically would make your previous
silver versions into a beautiful matte
block just like this is heavier he feels
about the same so this is my hero 4 I
had the hero4 black but I really wanted
to have the LCD panel in the back which
is great because this one does have the
LCD panel on the back this is a very
nice little housing that it has here
already give it a little skin well scoop
here's the front top we need to we need
to continue on I need to find myself a
battery oh god no don't tell me you
charge with USB see oh come on now
I'm not upset this USB see I'm mostly
just upset because I don't want to carry
another thing I was so excited with the
fact that this might be a micro SD
because usually Oh
I carried on someone's freakin clothes
this one used to be the mini-usb and the
session was a micro so if I only had one
or the other
I couldn't charge one of them so now
it's USBC which is even more difficult
to get my hands on if I'm out and about
hey does anybody here have a USBC cable
shoot this one better be USBC as well to
open up the battery you just push this
little button slide it and there you
have the nice little battery compartment
I did order one extra battery I tried to
order two and at checkout it said I'm
sorry you cannot order more than one
battery for shipment so there we are
with this right in there
pulls it up there's another little side
panel here which has a ratchet charge
port and your HDMI out SD card goes
right there press this to turn it on
yeah buddy
look at that nice LCD screen I don't
want a tour okay let's do the door short
press power on long press powers off
switch between video loads and photo
modes in the little mode button there on
the side so a short press for video a
long press for time-lapse photos so here
the first little menu setups we've got
our resolution frames per second in our
field of view wow it looks
oh god it's already recording holy moly
we're recording right now in 1080 60
frames a second so let's look up that's
you guys that's what you're seeing here
and this is oh what did I hit you I'm so
sorry so here's a little display on the
front I like that they moved the red
light with a little bit more subtle so
you can at least see that it's recording
but it's not so obnoxious and just
overtaking the whole camera also got a
little red light recording here in the
back
what you know that things are happening
it feels nice it's a good substantial
feel so let's take a peek of it in
comparison to the previous version of
the GoPro so it definitely looks I mean
all in all it's the same size but this
little lens here has definitely made it
a little bit thicker they feel about the
same weight also I'm not a very good
judge of gadget weights feel the same
pretty much this is one of my favorite
GoPro attachments this is actually
supposed to be used for the head mount I
have used this thing and clipped it to
every possible place I mostly use it
when I'm doing GoPro driving vlog flip
it to the air conditioner this
definitely can be used multiple ways not
just for the head piece right now it's
time for the hero five session what's
interesting about both of these GoPros
is they are now voice-activated so you
can tell it to take a picture or record
video now the first time that I sort of
got into the voice recording things back
in the day with a bit Google glass and I
was hanging off the side of a glacier
yelling at my eyes to take a picture so
I'm hoping that this works a lot better
than that I sometimes am a little
skeptical about voice-activated devices
if I would have followed these beautiful
photos I would have known that I have to
lift this and then squeeeeeeze
interesting that other one like that too
yeah this is this is new you lift this
up and then squeeze
that's so much easier so here is the
session
you're beautiful looks very much like a
previous session
so this Hero 5 session will do 4k at 30
frames a second 1440 at 60 and 1080 at
90 frames and in comparison to the Hero
5 it'll do 4k at 30 frames 1440 at 80
frames and 1080p at 120 so this just
comes out of its little skeleton as well
I'm gonna go grab my Ruby session please
hold I'm going to get all of these
things confused for Shore hero session 5
previous session it honestly looks so
much alike that I if I get these two
mixed up I'm going to have a very hard
time telling them apart
here is our identifiers the hero 5 has a
colored GoPro logo written on the back
and also on the front it's a very slight
difference the hero 5 session has
lighter gray wolf screws if that's
something that you can even tell on this
video and you kind of can it's this one
catch it right in the light you never I
get annoyed this isn't USB see I'm
throwing this thing across the room
thank you thank you
GoPro gods it is USB see the
inconsistency across the session and the
previous heroes was driving me nuts so
this is great news even though I'm still
a little bit upset about the USB see
it's ok I'll let it go I dunno what's
the future look for the future yet so
now I'd like to do a little camera an
audio test of the old session versus the
new session new hero 5 previous hero 4
so just set you right here
okay so this is a test of the hero
session first-gen what do you guys think
how's it look how's it sound what's it
sound like hello hero session five how's
it going hope you guys are doing really
really well
just wondering how this video compares
to the previous clip from the original
hero session and now here is the test of
the new hero 5 from GoPro GoPro Hero 5
would you guys think how's that look how
does it sound
I am mostly concerned about the sound
because that is that's always the debate
what's it sound like and here we are
with the previous version it's the hero
4 this is a hero 4 silver what's up
how's it going I do have a hero 4 black
somewhere but I'm not sure where that is
here's our rechargeable battery I
thought that I got a rechargeable
battery a little pack that you could
charge more than one at the same time
unfortunately the batteries are not the
same as the previous versions here's the
GoPro battery 4 here 5 you can see
there's already
quite the difference so I think the best
news out of all of this is even if you
do get a new GoPro all of your old
mounts and things will work the housing
will not work because it's clearly a
completely different size to GoPro but
all of your attachments and accessories
will definitely work so that is very
good news so I can take off my very very
favorite headband and mount it to this
little guy and there we are ready for
vlogging or adventures thank you guys so
much for watching let me know what you
guys think of the new GoPro Hero 5 in
the Hero 5 session or you GoPro fan what
is your most favorite thing about GoPro
for me it's portability I love being
able to just throw movies in my purse
when I'm not able to take a full rig or
a camera out to wherever I'm going I
know I can always throw it over over my
purse and I'm set especially with this
session man they're so small and so
little like still inconspicuous it's
like are you vlogging are you talking to
a smell Q bow signal ater bye
that's working out pretty good
Wow get up yeah me
this will place our fillets on top of
their nice little bed